you'll never master skateboarding
similarly I don't think you can really
master a siege may CJ kinda came out of
nowhere when somebody says like bro I
just got Maisie Jade you just died to
some dumb stuff that you now will use
for the rest of the time you play this
game too may CJ the world just makes
more sense with wood wheels and crypt
ape beneath his feet but after he broke
his ankle and a skateboarding accident
he faced a dilemma as referred to as a
zombie foot the whole thing was a yellow
Macy's primary creative pursuit was put
on hold and he was getting restless
I ended up breaking my foot so that kind
of like stopped for two months and all I
did was play seat
raela succeeds maybe a shooter but there
are a lot of things that set it apart
from a game like overwatch or csgo team
composition is more important than
another game sure but so is map
awareness siege asked players to find
creative ways to get around the map
while demanding they make quick precise
decisions as far as video games go it's
not that far from skateboarding it was
tactical but creative precise but
freewheeling it was exactly what Maisie
was looking for well that is like the
greatest injury to ever happen to me
well because it brought siege to me
Maisie took the siege immediately and
his creativity led to some moments that
seemed almost impossible Maisie had a
knack for creating compelling how the
[ __ ] did he do that plays which made for
some pretty incredible content
I didn't I didn't by merging high-level
play with his natural creativity Macy
gave the Seas community exactly what
they didn't know they wanted Oh No all
right I hate you chat I hate you all I
want to hear a word out of anybody okay
and it all started with a bit of c4 and
what the community considered to be the
worst operator in the game I can hear
someone Oh a shield coming it's coming
Macy came to siege well the game was
still new most people were still trying
to figure out the game's more
complicated mechanics and his
innovations a breath of fresh air he had
the right ideas at the right time he's
invented strategies and tactics
fundamentally changed the way the game
was played he sees them now the c-4 kill
is playing to the end of the roundabout
does it go Maci's inventive strategies
also changed the way pros played at the
highest level take team Empire at the
Raleigh major for example we're not
saying that they saw Macy too few the
bomb through a wall and followed suit
but hey he didn't do it first
oh my god okay when people say like bro
I just got Maisie Jade or like I'm anime
CJ this guy it's because a lot of people
will watch his videos and see these
really goofy cheeky angles that you
don't know existent like from underneath
viewer from above you and it's just like
I didn't know that you could do that
there's so many fun and quirky little
spots that he finds macy's innovations
influence the pros and if you want to
see those pros at their best make sure
to tune in to boot Aesop's US Nationals
2019 you can find out more information
in the links in the description below
anyway Macey took his what if mindset
cultivated by years of skateboarding and
applied it to seeds
what if I shot out this wall drop down
to the ledge and hopped across the map
see something cool chat that I just
learned what if I position my yokai
drone perfectly on this windowsill and
just picked off the dudes running
outside what if I fired a concussion
grenade through a vent while my teammate
reached the bomb site
let's go with every new patch map or
operator may see open people's eyes to
the cool [ __ ] you could pull off with
just a little bit of practice to be
around relative to the hatch around
there so we're gonna rotate back out I'm
gonna hold tiny tiny pixel Oh No
what if I miss and I'm c4 in the vigil
easy clap couple that with his genuine
and positive personality and his channel
exploded in popularity my god my god it
got to the point where his knack for
introducing weird but impactful
strategies got his name turned into a
verb may CJ kind of came out of nowhere
and he was extremely friendly he was
really nice humble down-to-earth and
extremely helpful you came for the
insane gameplay let's but you've stayed
for his goofy personality and the fact
that he doesn't take himself too
seriously
one friendly operator remaining
or eliminated but that popularity can
also be a double-edged sword I can't
even play the game now without people
recognizing me and that's great you know
like I'm grateful for it but you know
people can try and be toxic and in
trying to make siege a full-time gig
Macy has been pretty open about the wall
that a lot of streamers and content
creators run into the thing is I don't
see it this way if I if I don't feel
like I want to work I can still go to
work and do a good job but I don't think
that's the case with streaming if I
don't feel like streaming I don't think
I can do a good job the way that mates
the approaches siege allows everyone to
feel welcome after thousands of hours
he's still learning new things about the
game and his community is along for the
ride learning with him he wouldn't call
himself an expert he's just a dude who
approaches each match with a fresh set
of eyes the same way he'd approached
skateboarding and was a griptape wood
and wheels aren't under his feet as
often these days whenever Macy jumps
onto a server the spirit of his first
creative love is always with him
- Macey J is the [ __ ] thing in the
shot because it is right in front of the
camera I know but I'm afraid dude it's
like right in front of the camera I know
but you've got a I'm not an expert man
you gotta you gotta you gotta help the
little people